here is one of the trained model for
minis image classification as a response
to the common criticism that Mechelen
models are not interpretable let's have
a closer look at the trained model
parameters each line here represents one
model parameter for all the parameters
connected to the one output we could
transform them into a 2d image for
example here is a 2d image for all the
model parameters connected to the first
output which represent the digit zero
here the yellow color represents the
weights have large values and the blue
color represents the weights have small
values the following figures shows the
weights visualization for each digit
from 0 to 9 it is pretty clear to see
how each figure highlights or activates
different parts of the images
corresponding to different digit classes
using this model for each input image in
the test dataset we can calculate the
luggage score of each digit class with
the linear weighted sum of the model
with W and input X in this way we can
classify the input image into one of the
classes with the highest luggage score
here
let's also record the prediction result
for each test image in a confusion
matrix for the first example we have the
input image as 8 and the prediction is 8
and for the second example we have the
input image as 5 and that the prediction
is 6 the confusion matrix is reputable
way of visualizing the performance of in
the image classification model each
entry in the confusion matrix denotes
the number of predictions that were made
by the models will it classify the image
correctly or incorrectly after iterating
through all the test data set we can
derive recall precision and f1 score for
each class here I will not dive deep
into how to calculate them where the
details can be found in our confusion
matrix video this is the code block to
do the evaluation
the results looks very good for these
simple classification problems with a
simple softmax regression model it is a
relatively easy task in image
classification in the future video we
will show you how to extend this model
and Papp line to solve more difficult
problems with more complicated models
such as convolutional neural network
don't forget to subscribe to us and rain
the notification bell and stay tuned